we met under those circumstances and i
remember being intimidated by you that's
not how we met
fuck
you don't remember this give it i don't
so when you talk
so this is how and i don't know if i can
you can cut it later no no we don't
please okay uh and i i re-told you this
story at workaholics because you didn't
remember it
um
we went out to dinner when i had been in
la for
maybe a year and you'd been there for
maybe like six months
we went out to dinner with
jordan rubin
and
sean lennon who jordan grew up with
right
and
my wife my girlfriend now wife was there
too and i was like she had just moved
out here because she's younger than me
uh i was still finishing school she just
came out here and i was like hey we're
going to go to dinner with this guy
jordan he's a stand-up super funny and i
think sean lennon is going to be this
dinner
and she was like
what like why would shawn london want to
go to dinner with you you fucking loser
my boyfriend um she keeps me grounded
and we go to dinner and you're there and
you
you
are so much fun at this dinner and i'm
like so like i'm like
this person's gonna be so famous so fast
and you
jordan was like we played a game the
other day
he was living with simon rex
do you know what it is
okay
i do know this okay so let me let me
just yeah couple footnotes and we will
tell the story about this game
so
i you know when sometimes you ask
someone for directions and as soon as
they start telling you the directions
you zone out and start like looking at
their freckles and so so when i
at workaholics i was disassociating
because i was nervous like i do
specifically remember talking to you at
your off in your office in that like
dark hallway did you hear you the lock
when i hit the button under my desk
matlab the matt lauer button
so i remember specifically going i want
to meet this person i want to talk to
this person i'm a fan don't embarrass
yourself i already was in a little bit
of like i don't i mean you are in every
movie that's been released in the last
uh seven years so
are you ever on a set and you're just
like
you get insecure and you're just like
yeah of course yeah i was just insecure
a thousand percent and i remember
talking to you and being like
looking down at myself going like pay
attention to what he's saying he's
trying to talk to you but then my brain
was like he's just trying to be nice to
you even though you're ruining his show
there was i will have i can have
conversations with people where i just
go offline
and because i was in fear like i was in
total fight or flight mode and like
scared i was ruining your show
um
so i don't remember you
telling me this story at work
full disclosure i don't remember you
retelling me this story i'm still an
asshole fair no no yeah so we were at a
bar one night and there was a game that
was being played oh it was at a bar it
was at a bar it was called the well yeah
a place called the well yeah yeah i'm in
the well mm-hmm and i like
and digital cameras
were brand new it was a k
easy
right i mean it was a camera that was
like had the screen on yeah but it was
like it wasn't connected to a phone it
wasn't connected to a phone and it was
it was there was an era where like
people would bring out digital cameras
as kind of like a flex to be like i've
got money and like
i do this and jordan was like a
filmmaker so he had like a nice game yes
he's always been like a photographer
type of guy yeah and it's a camera where
you could take a picture and then you
could see the photo right and he was
like it was me simon rex maybe like two
other random people like girls
and they're like let's play a game where
everybody goes in the bathroom take the
dirtiest picture you can craziest the
craziest picture
okay it was like take the craziest
picture you can think of don't and then
the next person
does it but you're not allowed to look
at what the people before you did and
let's see who just in a vacuum who took
the craziest picture
right so
the funniest thing to me is that jordan
goes so here's my picture and it's
jordan with his doing a mangina he puts
his dick between his legs and shows like
a mangina right picture and then and
then he goes here's simon rex's it was
the exact same thing coincidentally and
then a girl one of the girls did a photo
of just her pee
going into the toilet right and then
what was your photo mine was
finger in the asshole
and
jordan was like we were shocked
like
we kind of wish the game didn't happen
like it crossed the line
but like obviously made the story and my
wife who had just moved to hollywood
gets like jordan passes the camera
around you're like i don't care whatever
it's so stupid yeah sure and i look out
i go
mm-hmm and my wife's like can i see i go
yeah look and then we're like what is
that and then because it was like a
weird angle
and then it was it's hard to take a
picture of your finger in your own
asshole it's not it
so in the drive home was fascinating
my wife's like yeah i don't what are we
doing out here i'm gonna be famous i
have to be seen
[Music]
[Applause]